تعويضات لحامليه تذاكر نهائي باريس
مانشستر يونايتد يستهين بطبيب نفسي وفاه
لاعب افواري خلال مباراه فريقه هذه
الاخبار وغيرها تتابعون على العربيه رياضه
اهلا بكم
بعد نحو ثمانيه اشهر من لاعب نهائي دوري
ابطال اوروبا ليستعد للاتحاد الاوروبي
لكره القدم لتعويض حامل التذاكر الذين لم
يتمكنوا من حضور المباراه بعد الفوضى التي
تسببت بها شرطه باريس ولم يتمكن نحو 20
الف مشجع لفريق ليفربول من حضور مباراه
فريقهم امام ريال مدريد بسبب تزوير
التذاكر ومن المتوقع ان يبلغ تعويض
الجماهير نحو ثلاثه ملايين ونصف مليون
يورو
سبعه اهداف نظيفه نتيجه لم يتقبلها لاعب
مانشستر يونايتد وخاصه انها امام الغريم
التقليدي وجاءت بعد سلسله نتائج ايجابيه
مدرب الفريق تنهاك لجا الى طبيب نفسي
هولندي لمعالجه لاعبه بالعوده بشكل اقوى
لكن تنهاك وقبل جلسه العلاج ارغم لاعبيه
على مشاهده ملخص للمباراه التاريخيه
لاخراج الغضب الذي بداخلهم مع الطبيب
النفسي
بعد نحو ثلاثه اسابيع من خوضهم مباراه
الذهاب امام ميلان ستكون عوده بدلاء
توتنهام متزامنه مع مباراه الاياب ضد نادي
الايطالي وكان كونتي قد بقي في ايطاليا
خلال الفتره الماضيه بامر من طبيبه الخاص
ولم يتمكن من قياده فريقه في المسابقات
المحليه ويسع انطونيو صاحب السجل المتواضع
الاوروبيا للوصول الى ربع نهائي دوري
الابطال للمره الثانيه في تاريخه
في خبرنا الاخير توفي اللاعب الافواري
مصطفى سيلا خلال مباراه فريق ابي جون في
الدوري المحلي وانهار اللاعب البالغ من
العمر 21 عاما فوق الملعب محاولات اسعافها
لم تنجح وفارق الحياه قبل وصوله الى
المستشفى وهذا بحسب ما اعلن النادي عبر
موقعه الرسمي